هذا ما يريدك الطالبان أن
تعرف أن لحظتهم قادمة وهم
مستعدون للنصر ، هذا عالم
ربما لم تره من قبل عن قرب ،
فنحن بعض الصحفيين الغربيين
الوحيدين الذين دخلوا إليه ، وهو عدو أمريكا
في أفغانستان المعروف
بإيوائه.  أسامة بن لادن بينما كان
يخطط لهجمات 11 سبتمبر / أيلول بسبب
قمعه الوحشي للمرأة
ولتحقيق عدالة قاسية بموجب
تفسير متشدد للشريعة الإسلامية ،
نريد أن نعرف من تكون طالبان
اليوم إذا كان ذلك بعد 17 عامًا من الحرب مع
الولايات المتحدة.  لقد غيرت إمارتهم الإسلامية
رحلتنا التي بدأت في
مدينة مزار الشريف الشمالية ، حيث أُجبرت طالبان
على الانسحاب من هنا بعد معركة مريرة
في عام 2001 ، وهم الآن على بعد
أميال قليلة ، ونحن نتجه الآن للقاء.
مرافقتنا من طالبان وكما
ترون أنا أرتدي الحجاب الكامل للوجه
المعروف بالنقاب الذي أرتديه لأبقى
بعيدًا عن الأنظار قدر الإمكان
لأنه لا يوجد صحفيون غربيون
في المناطق التي نتجه إلى
سيطرة الحكومة  الطريق السريع
خارج المدينة ، ولكن بمجرد أن تغلق الطريق الرئيسي ،
تكون سريعًا في
منطقة طالبان للوصول إلى مضيفينا ، يتعين علينا
عبور نهر صغير على متن عبارة تم ضخ مليارات
الدولارات الأمريكية في
بناء البنية التحتية لأفغانستان
ولكن القليل من ذلك  لقد تسللت إلى
هنا ،
هذا هو مرافقتنا هناك على
الجانب الآخر من النهر بعد شهور من
المفاوضات ، وافقت قيادة طالبان
على منح المخرج الأفغاني
نجيب الله قريشي نفسي والمنتج
سلمى عبد العزيز  نادرًا
ما نتمكن من الوصول إلى سينما أراضي المجموعة
كنساء يتم تجاهلنا على ما يبدو غير مرئي
تحت الحجاب الكامل وهو أمر إلزامي
في الأماكن
العامة ، فقد سمحت لنا طالبان بزيارة
هذه المناطق لأنها تريد أن تظهر
أنها مسيطر عليها ولكن في لحظاتنا الأولى ، ما
هذا؟  يخبرنا الكثير من المروحيات ،
واحد اثنان ثلاثة أربعة خمسة ،
مرافقتنا أن نتوقف ، نحن الآن على الجانب الآخر
من حرب أمريكا في الأشهر الأخيرة
، صعدت الولايات المتحدة بشكل كبير من
عدد الضربات الجوية على طالبان ،
علم المسلحين يجعلنا هدفًا واضحًا
نحن  ليس أمامنا خيار سوى الضغط على
محطتنا الأولى ، وهي عيادة
يديرها طالبان منذ
سيطرتهم على هذه المنطقة منذ ما يقرب من عامين
، تكشف لوحة على الباب أنها كانت
هدية من الأمريكيين في عام 2006
فجأة فتاة صغيرة  صدمت
دراجة
نارية بالخارج فتى يندفع لمساعدتها السائق
هو مقاتل من طالبان يرفع بندقيته
على كتفه ويتجول على
ما يبدو أن الحياة غير المكترثة هنا
وحشية  تندفع الفتاة إلى داخل
أم مسعورة تتبع وراءها ولكن لا
يبدو أن أحدًا مصدومًا لأننا
الطبيب يعطي والدتها بعض
المسكنات ويشعر بها بعيدًا بعد سنوات من
القتال هنا ، لقد رأى الأمر أسوأ بكثير
من المسؤول عن المستشفى الذي
يديره وأوضح  أن طالبان
تدير العيادة ولكن الحكومة
تدفع الرواتب وتوفر الأدوية ، أصبح هذا
النوع من التعاون المخصص
أكثر شيوعًا وهناك
تغييرات أخرى كانت هناك قابلة تبلغ من العمر 22 عامًا
حيث عمل الله في ظل حكم
طالبان و  الحكومة الأفغانية ،
ما هي تجربتك في العمل
تحت حكم طالبان هنا ، لم تتدخل طالبان أبدًا
، وعملنا هو النساء التي تقول
إنهم لم يمنعونا أبدًا من القدوم إلى
العيادة في منطقة الانتظار ، وتقول هؤلاء النساء
إن الحرب والفقر هو ما يجعل
حياتهن بائسة  تغيرت الحياة تحت حكم
طالبان الآن عما كانت عليه
قبل أي شيء ، نحن محاصرون في
المنتصف تقول المرأة ولا يمكننا فعل أي شيء
، من المحزن جدًا رؤيته  ما مدى يأس
الناس هنا ، حيث تخبرك النساء
أنه ليس لديهن ما يكفي من الطعام لتناوله ،
وليس لديهن الأدوية المناسبة لعلاج
أطفالهن المعاقين ، كل ما يريدونه هو
التبول
وبعض التحسن في نوعية
حياتهم ، لقد تأخر الوقت ونحن بحاجة
للوصول إلى سكننا ، تقوم طالبان
بإيقاف خدمة الهاتف المحمول بعد حلول الظلام ،
هذا هو الوقت الذي نكون فيه أكثر عرضة للخطر
في صباح اليوم التالي ، حيث تم نقلنا إلى
مدرسة دينية أو مدرسة دينية تحت
حكم طالبان في التسعينيات من القرن الماضي ، تم
منع الفتيات من الذهاب إلى المدرسة ولكننا وجدنا
الأولاد والبنات الذين يدرسون يرفعون يدك
إذا كنت تعرف كيف تقرأ ، حسنًا ، واحد اثنان ثلاثة
يمكنك القراءة والكتابة ، هل تعرف ما
تريد أن تكون عندما تكبر يا دكتور
برافو
ما هو موضوعك المفضل في المدرسة
الرياضيات ، أنت معلم ذكي يار
يقسم محمد وقته بين الصفوف الأمامية
والفصل الدراسي. ak-47 لا يغادر
جانبه أبدًا ، وقد أصدرت الإمارة تعليمات
لأقسام التعليم للسماح
بتعليم فتيات الدراسات الدينية.
والرياضيات كما يقول ، ولكن
هناك مشكلة
بمجرد وصولهن إلى سن البلوغ ، لا تستطيع الفتيات الذهاب
إلى المدرسة مع الأولاد ، والحقيقة المحزنة
هي أن قلة في المناطق الريفية مثل هذه ترى
تعليم المرأة كأولوية
ينصب تركيز طالبان الآن على إظهار أنها
يمكن أن تحكم بشكل فعال في جميع أنحاء البلاد.
الدولة التي عينتها المجموعة
حكام الظل مثل ماو ، صقور v-
hawks لأمنه دائمًا ما تكون الصقور في حالة
تنقل عندما يسمع القرويون أنه
يزورهم يصطفون بسرعة للتعبير
عن قضاياهم ، وهناك خلافات حول
المال وملكية الأراضي
سيتم التعامل مع
أربعة صقور غدًا يقولون إن الفساد
منتشر في الحكومة الأفغانية وأن
طالبان تتمتع بسمعة طيبة في تحقيق
العدالة بسرعة إذا كانت الإمارات الإسلامية
لديها قوانين يقول هذا الرجل إن لديها
نظامًا للشريعة الإسلامية في مكانه يوافق Huck's R
على الجلوس معها  نحن حارسه الشخصي
يستمع إلى التحديثات الأمنية على
الراديو نبدأ بالسؤال عن
التكتيكات الوحشية لطالبان والولايات المتحدة
قلقون من أنهم قد يقدمون مرة أخرى
ملاذًا آمنًا للإرهابيين سواء كانوا
الأمريكيين أو داعش ،
فلن يُسمح للقوات الأجنبية بدخول البلاد
بمجرد أن نبدأ في حكم أفغانستان ،
فهل هناك جهود حقيقية تُبذل لوقف
قتل المدنيين.
أتت بطائراتها المدفعية B-52
والأسلحة الثقيلة في الواقع
طالبان هي المسؤولة عن
مقتل آلاف المدنيين في السنوات الثلاث الماضية
وحدها وماذا عن هذه
التفجيرات الانتحارية في مراكز الاقتراع على سبيل المثال
هذه التفجيرات تقتل العديد من المدنيين ونحن ننفي
هذا الاتهام ليس  مقبول لدينا ،
هناك علامات صغيرة على أن حركة
طالبان تتحرك مع الأوقات التي أستمع فيها إلى
الراديو وكذلك Facebook ووسائل الإعلام الأخرى ، نعم ،
لكن من الواضح أن الأيديولوجية الأساسية
لم تتغير ، لذلك إذا
وجد شخص ما مذنبًا بسرقةك
بقطع يده ، نعم  نحن
نطبق الشريعة ونتبع تعليمات الشريعة الإسلامية إذا
ثبتت إدانة شخص ما بارتكاب الزنا
فسترجمه  حتى الموت ، نعم ،
تسمح الشريعة بالرجم حتى الموت مع مغادرتنا
المقابلة ، يصل القائد
العسكري للمنطقة وينشب خلاف
عنا ، كان عليهم
إحضار رجل يقول أحدهم
القضية الآن لا يريدوننا.
لقد اتفقنا على متابعة الرجال عن بعد ، وهو
أمر لم أضطر إلى القيام به
في حياتي المهنية ، يأخذنا القائد mu bar هو
رأس Buju إلى منزل آمن قريب
لإجراء مقابلة خاصة بنا ، وقد تم
تحذيرنا من أن الأسئلة السياسية غير
مطروحة على الطاولة ، أليس كذلك؟  تريد أن ترى السلام
بين طالبان وأمريكا ،
سيكون من الأفضل إذا تم طرح هذا السؤال
على المتحدث الرسمي باسم الإمارة الإسلامية ،
هل تشعر أن طالبان
تنتصر في الحرب إن شاء الله نتمنى أن
نكون مدعومين من الله يريد
أن يتباهى بها.  قواته من أجل كاميراتنا
يتجمع رجاله خارج القرية ،
من النادر والخطير
للغاية أن يتجمع عشرات المقاتلين في
مكان واحد أتيت إلى
أفغانستان منذ أكثر من 10 سنوات.
لم أتخيل مطلقًا أنني سأقوم بإعداد التقارير
من هنا في قلب أراضي طالبان ،
لكننا لن نبقى
هنا طويلًا لأن تجمعات مثل هذه
يمكن أن تكون هدفًا رئيسيًا للضربات الجوية ،
لكن القائد يقول إن الجيش الأمريكي
قد لا يمكنه منعهم من الانتصار
نحن مستعدون لأية تضحيات لا
نخاف من التعرض للضرب هذا هو طريقنا المقدس ،
نواصل جهادنا معظم هؤلاء
الرجال كانوا يقاتلون القوات الأمريكية منذ
أن كانوا كبارًا بما يكفي لحمل السلاح
والسؤال الآن هل هم مستعدون لوضع
هؤلاء  تقترب زيارتنا
لطالبان من نهايتها ، فقد حان الوقت
لمغادرة
[الموسيقى]
لجزء كبير من أفغانستان ،
ولا يزال احتمال عودة طالبان مرعبًا ، لكن بالنسبة للكثيرين هنا ،
لا يوجد فرق كبير بين من هو المسؤول
بعد عقود من الحرب و
سوف يلجأون إلى المشقة إلى أي شخص يعدك
بالسلام